in this video I'm gonna be skipping the
specs and focusing on the real-world
differences after switching from my
beloved iPhone 11 pro max to the s20
ultra for one week and I have to say
that there are two specific reasons that
make me really want to stay using the
Samsung and finally ditch Apple which
I'll talk about in just a bit this was
the first phone that I used the case on
in many years I hate using cases because
it covers up the amazing build quality
and makes them much thicker and heavier
unfortunately even though the s20 ultra
is both taller and thicker than the
11pro max the camera bump is even
thicker and not only does a phone sit
really crooked on a desk but holding in
my hands my finger kept being cut into
by the camera module which doesn't
happen with my iPhone or the note 10
plus it was also pretty much impossible
not to get fingerprints on the camera
while holding horizontally which isn't
an issue with most new phones did I get
used to the large size surprisingly yes
but afterwards going back to the 11pro
max the phone seemed so thin and small
which is something that I thought I
would never say about it next the auto
brightness is stupid maybe it's only
because it's been a week but it's
constantly either too dark or at times
too bright whereas the iPhone gets it
right most of the time I also missed
face ID it just works so well and it's
so fast that most the time I don't even
notice it I mostly used the fingerprint
sensor but I did also try face and lock
for one day of course it isn't as secure
but I wanted to see if it's just as
convenient and it's not you do have more
options but it takes longer to unlock
your phone especially in lower lighting
and at times it doesn't work at all
thankfully the fingerprint sensor has
been much improved since the S 10 and
the note 10 it works fast and pretty
much every time but it's still not as
convenient as face ID I especially
missed it for authentication and apps or
websites where face ID is just automatic
now the screen is gorgeous especially in
1440p mode it is really really nice for
watching movies honestly the best phone
ever and definitely Trump's the iPhone
11 Pro max first off I love having the
1440p option in YouTube that
noticeably more detail than 1080p next
one is HDR this is the first time that
HDR shows a huge significantly
noticeable difference compared to
good-quality
SDR on a phone and it's really
impressive and clearly better than the
iPhone not only that but the speakers
are quite a bit louder as well
[Music]
I'm glad that Samsung has really stepped
up at Spieker game in the last two years
I usually run the iPhone at about 90% or
so but the s20 was just fine at 70% and
in those cases where you have a quiet
video or you're in a loud room and I
want to share a video having the extra
volume is so nice to have the only
downside with the speakers is that you
really feel the case of the phone
vibrate when you're running above 70%
which could be annoying if you're
watching the long video whereas the
iPhone is solid even maxed out but of
course it doesn't get as loud I also
love the split sound adjustments and the
mode that allows notifications to come
through the phone and not the Bluetooth
speaker you're connected to
I really wish my iPhone had these
features along with other Android
features such as picture and picture
YouTube videos chromecast controls and
notifications sticking in the top bar
until I clear them so I don't forget
things now the killer feature of the
display is that 120 Hertz paired with
the fast animations and man do I love it
I especially love it when scrolling
through websites where the lack of
motion blur looks really nice and going
back to my iPhone it just feels so slow
and laggy now there are downsides and
it's not just battery life which of
course is affected if you're using 120
Hertz you have to be in 1080p mode and I
have to say that I did notice it if this
was a five and a half inch screen I may
have not noticed it but being that this
thing is almost 7 inches you can clearly
see it especially in text now the other
downside of course is battery life this
is the first time in a while where I've
had to top off every evening which I've
only had to do on my pro max if I forgot
to charge it the night before I would
have to say that for my usage pattern
and my background apps it's a difference
of about two hours of screen on time in
the 120 Hertz mode and that's using the
default optimized power mode and without
the always-on display if you've never
experienced the freedom of not having to
worry about your battery life that the
iPhone 11 pro max offers then you might
not understand it but it is amazing and
going back to having the top off
throughout the day or an evening is a
bigger deal than I expected once I knew
that I had to top off the phone anyways
I switched to high performance mode and
I turned on the always-on display which
a feature I personally really like and I
wish that my iPhone had even if it would
use extra battery I really wish that
Samsung had the promotion tech of the
iPad pro where it could jump from 120
Hertz down to 60 or even down to 24
Hertz depending on what you're doing
which really helps save battery life
most of our YouTube videos are at 24 fps
and in that case the GPU and the screen
have to put out five times more frames
than necessary needlessly draining that
battery hopefully the iPhone 12 will
have the promotion tech of the iPad and
at full resolution as well and now on to
what I probably love the most and where
I noticed the biggest difference between
my iPhone 11 Pro Max and the s20 ultra
and that is the data speeds and the
reception Samsung has been ahead of
Apple and LTE speeds for a while now
which I loved with the note 10 but the
s20 ultra takes it to a whole new level
now does depend on what provider you use
and where you live but I used t-mobile
and they have the sub 6 5g across the US
this isn't a millimeter wave insanely
fast 5g but one that penetrates
buildings better I often got one or two
bars more with s 20 which is great but
what's even better is the speeds which
were routinely 2 to 3 times faster than
my iPhone during this testing I got my
fastest speed I have ever seen on my
iPhone which was 65 megabits per second
download but in that same scenario the
s20 got 162 and the download speed was
49 instead of 19 the test before that my
iPhone got 25 and the Samsung got about
95 and during peak time with lower
reception the Samsung got 27 megabit per
second while my iPhone got 9 now these
are just speed test numbers so what does
this mean in the real world well a whole
lot actually when I'm using LTE I often
have to limit YouTube videos to 720p or
else I get pauses whereas the Samsung
placed back smoothly at 1440p an initial
buffering of videos is almost
unnoticeable with s20 where I do have to
wait on my iPhone you also notice a
difference when loading websites and if
you're downloading apps and other media
and this is especially noticeable if
you're
constantly in steel or concrete
buildings or basements and ultimately it
could make a difference between having a
signal or not having one at all I really
really really hope that we do have a 5g
option on the upcoming iPhone 12 and if
we don't at least a much better modem
because the difference is huge and for
some people this difference alone is
enough to switch brands another
noticeable difference is call volume and
the s20 ultra is definitely quieter
which because a problem if the person on
the other side isn't very loud
I found myself constantly trying to
press the phone really deep kind of into
my ear and trying to up the volume to
make sure it's maxed out and I think
that might be because this little
speaker is just hidden inside of the
frame here now such on the cameras I
really enjoyed using the note tents
camera but the s20 ultras had me missing
and the iPhone there are two big
features the 108 megapixel main camera
and that 100 times zoom but just because
we have these big specs to flaunt
doesn't mean that they actually work
well I have to say that the autofocus is
garbage I unseen this poor performance
in many years if ever the new sensors
inside the s20 ultra are much bigger
than before
but we also have much less focused
pixels so it is slow at focusing and it
will randomly hunt whereas the iPhone is
ultra fast smooth and accurate this
means that although we do have some
advantages in the actual quality if
you're missing the shot and it's out of
focus then what is the point now in good
lighting I love the 48 megapixel zoom
lens which has so much more detail but
because it lets in so much less light at
F 3.7 in medium and low lighting the
quality is worse than Apple's 12
megapixel 2 times zoom cropped in which
is effectively a 6 megapixel image there
are also major limitations for portrait
shots and for video and after testing
the a K video I have to say that it's
just a marketing tactic and in many
cases the iPhones 4k video looks better
than this 8k there's so much more to
talk about in terms of camera
performance both good and bad so I'm
gonna have to save that for the full
detailed s20 ultra review
so make sure that you guys are
subscribed now the other thing that I
absolutely loved and what made me want
to switch brands is the rim with the
11pro I often try to reopen something I
was doing say a half-hour ago and I find
it closed and has to relaunch this is so
annoying
especially for apps where you have a
video open or a document not once that I
have this issue with the s20 I routinely
opened apps the next day and everything
was as I left it at one point I had 18
apps running and I opened the oldest one
in list which was vainglory and it was
right as I left at 18 hours ago Apple
please stop
barely bumping up your RAM especially if
you're adding more soccer features that
uses more of it so overall how was the
experience switching over and will I say
with the Samsung honestly it was great
definitely more positive than negative
and I do wish I could switch but I can't
the iPhone is good hardware wise but
it's the software that really sells it
I missed iMessage and other things like
airplay which is better than chromecast
I missed controlling my Apple TV airdrop
continuity and of course my Apple watch
which I loved I found that some soccer
things just didn't work as well like
voice recognition for texting and I
really missed having Siri being able to
read my messages out loud and allowed me
to reply hands-free these are the things
that still hold a lot of people to the
iPhone but if Apple doesn't keep
innovating and trying to keep up with
things like RAM 5g and having faster
refresh rates on the screen then I may
have to take the plunge and move over to
Android let me know what you think down
below and click that circle above to
subscribe to see our full review and if
you want to see our detailed photo or
video comparisons they are right over
there this has been Max's max tech and I
will see you in the next video
[Music]